hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision medicine the
way forward
presented by Preston Mishra founder and
CEO of agility pharmaceuticals CEO of
American Association for precision
medicine I mix a tributary of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen what answers many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotion aboard at the
bottom and/or center of your screen or
use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now please join me in welcoming
dr. Mishra I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you thank
you for that kind introduction and hello
everyone today what I will try to do is
I'll try to give you we're all were all
overall bird's-eye view of the precision
medicine you know that what we have
learned what being trying to you know
what is the world goal and what are the
problem that we are trying to solve and
why you know what is the region and how
much we have accomplished so these are
my disclosures that I do not end
they discuss a off-label use and
commercial products in this educational
activity and this presentation reflects
my personal use and does not necessarily
reflect policies of the company that I
had founded upon them and wise are on
Stockton so this is a brief outline and
talking out what he co-edited so first
I'll like to use the few you know key
concepts I would like to begin with past
President Obama's code and that's why we
are here today because something called
precision medicine gives us one of the
greatest opportunities of new medical
breakthroughs that we have ever seen
historically precision medicine you know
evolution began with you know starting
up pharmacokinetics so we all studied
the inherited differences drug mini
ballers wall in government of all of
them in response and with the rise of
omics oh you know probably genomics came
into picture there we studied all the
many different genes that have been used
to determine from behavior in order to
improve the efficacy of truck and what I
have yeah there you go
so what we have then we then the field
you know of individualized medicine or
tail and medicine began and we name
personalized medicine came into picture
and what the what I call this as a
clinical application or pharmacokinetics
although the name was first very
personalized but you never intended you
know drugs are medical devices for each
patient but rather you know the ability
to classify individuals into
subpopulations
and that differ introduced
the disease are their responses Pacific
treatment so you know so so then you
know it was called precision medicine
you know which is a wiliest
name right now precision medicine is an
emerging approach for disease prevention
and treatment and that takes into
account people's people's individual
variations in genes micro mavens and
life starts again precision medicine
takes into account family history
medical genetics lifestyle and
environmental factors
so why precision medicine you know
Tiffany
most medical care is based on expected
response to an average patient and we
know that there is no average age
there's no such thing as a navigation so
you want to move away from that paradigm
to a medical care based on individuals
you know you know make environmental and
lifestyle differences or precise methods
to prevent and treat it so that
preventive and therapeutic interventions
and concentrated on benefit in sparing
the side effects to those who will not
so there are you know many classic
examples of precision medicine you know
it's not the concept is not entirely new
starting from testing for veera 367
mutations before treating the femoral
nerve to testing the disease-causing
mutations and Braja one and radicals
which are implicated in breast and
ovarian cancer risks and this is a you
know and there are many successful
examples but historically you know this
was some of the sometime around 2011
you know National Research Council's or
National Academies and you know was
given a pass to kind of you know they
found the field of the precision
medicine and suggest their
recommendations you know where we should
be going and they recommended to develop
a knowledge network so this will be data
from basic sciences and discovery as
well as clinical discovery following
into
information comes so this will be you
know molecular characterization data and
EHR electronic health records later they
will all be looking into the knowledge
network great where the various layers
of the classifiers with genomics micro
our longings epigenomics and then using
the integrating genomics all these
approach people create a taxonomic
classification that will be used again
to feel the basically research and
clinical discovery so this was this is
the fabulous you know vision but there
are there are you know certain
scientific challenges that we have faced
and we are solving them one of the
cancer field one of the first problem is
cheaper deprecating you know as you can
see here you know a patient can have
many different nations and so though
those lesions are can arise from
different cells
you know colonizing a tumor and also you
know if you look at one tumor and cell
the tumor itself is heterogeneous made
about different sections then we have
them you know we profile so this is the
first problem the same problem is tumor
evolution you can see humans tumors
again you know they have different
driving genes are different and and
mutations that driving relapsed they are
presented both frequency and when the
tumor relapses you know those mutation
Pradhan predominance so how do we treat
you know for that so that leads to the
anticipation based schemes are also
sheer number of mutations in cancers are
very high in this tube you know you can
see lung cancer as an example
non-small-cell lung cancer has 147
mutations lung cancer and the small cell
has 163 mutations so you know there are
a lot of mutations to target and also
mutation rates across the cancers are
not uniform can see melanoma being
the highest highly mutated cancers and
your last movie Louis cancers and in
melanoma you can see the c13
communication is predominant maybe this
is URI signature and in lung cancer you
can see c2 a predominant which may
represent a smoking signature so you
know our as as we have learned more our
our view of cancer has changed just to
take an example of lung cancer you know
traditionally be funded three different
kinds of lung cancer is almost Paula's
cell Harmony's Faunus large cell and
adenocarcinoma
then in late 1980s there Olaf Harris and
2004 EGFR and in 2009 we learned that
there are other human genes that were
involved be Ralph Matt you know Katie
ti3 okay but now in 2017 you know there
are many other genes and that drive this
you know and that could be druggable but
there is a you know there are a lot more
than needs to be learned yet about this
particular cancer so as we learn more we
realize that cancers are more complex as
we think so also the you know potential
non-coding regions you know this is all
we talked about right now is the coding
so you know as we learn from human you
know you're not you know you know coding
coding region if you see you presented
by protein coding genes is a small
fraction of human genome rest all is
fine and sign elements also pseudogenes
you know and if you see majority of the
you know main course unique non-coding
DNA thought to be a junkie anything but
this is non-coding DNA encodes my corn
is all sorts of non non-coding RNAs and
which may be very important
in our regulation in regulation of the
protein coding gene also when we grew up
from the summers ago when we evolved
from a simple to very complex organism
as human beings you know you see the
three prime UTR lengths of a gene a
protein coding gene did not you know
increase in land however you see our
three prime UTR kept on growing
suggesting that proteins in humans are
humans because they are regulated very
well the genes are regulated very well
genes have a modern idea that allows
more innovation and more regulation to
happen using the non non-coding RNA so
the so I studied this phenomenon in
detail and we put forward one one
schematics
that's well accepted in the field now
see you so you have micro RNA variant as
present in the three prime UTR origin
and that can knock off a micro RNA
binding site or when creating micro RNA
binding sites this you know if it's a
this may result in over expression of a
drug target or ohnkoji you know classic
wisdom and all the genes are the drug
targets and order express some drug
target can result in drug resistance and
result in cellular transformation on
pitching and since the micro RNA
regulators are poaching it will be you
know it will be a tumor suppressor micro
RNA and this field in the last ten years
or so has exploded in there
approximately you know two thousand
seven hundred articles in comments
suggesting that there's a there is some
sort of variance in different genes that
drive different diseases they they you
know the fact you know they somehow
affect those genes that drive the
diseases
and by creating or knocking off of my
poverty side resulting in you know
disease predisposition or are preventing
it cease to offer this mic or any column
our peasants are lucky and you know he
Marion they're encoded in the 3-prime
utr non-coding in which is literally a
charity which is usually you know
avoided in most of the sequencing
operations and the goal is that you know
some of these variants gonna be
populated in clinvar or cloned gen which
is you know because a consortium of to
create actionable genomic information to
clinicians at point of care so and one
more challenge that we see is if we you
have ompany that drives will immensely
try to block it you know what happens is
there's another ology you know it gets
activated after after sometime so that
we call an oncogene bypass and then the
combination therapy is a way closer find
which chakra gene has activated and then
be combining it with with the disease we
learned with a different drug and also
one of the challenge that we have been
facing is accuracy and disability out
loud a lot tests if you see in the
example in one of the first examples the
accuracy of this test which was you know
perform in 91 Laos is approximately 75%
so there is still you know so the way
forward there is a you know good news
that we have you know we have cost of
sequencing genome has gone down you do
advances at sequencing technologies now
sequence
gene for approximately thousand dollars
and the time of sequencing has been
reduced it and drastically
you know the two years children now less
than a day and two computing power power
is more than 16 times more than what the
heat has been you've been dead within 10
years banished and so again the cost of
cost per genome has defined Moore's law
and and you can see that it has gone
down dramatically to our benefit and the
technology itself the sequencing
technology itself has evolved and now
what we have done is you know sequence a
lot of respiration genomes to have a
very good consensus reference so if we
sequence a new new genome we can align
and we can get good sense of what are
the you know the good sense of the
alignments and which may be in the
region which is you know which variant
is important verses in which is just a
noise such so and these are the mentors
are right now in the client so this is a
slide from MD Anderson Cancer Center you
can see where patients are profile and
based on based on the mythology of
course our our sequencing information
and based on that data are you know from
Mashable
prognostic markers markers predictions
that have you resistance and markers to
predict adverse events are defined and
based on those markers patients are
stratified in different rules and in
assigned a different treatment regime
which is very very encouraging and also
another example of you know how to what
you know what are the cases that they
are seeing in the clients if you have
here you have three different patients
that are know that are presenting
themselves in the clinic one has an L v6
documentation second patient has
colorectal cancer near a v600e mutation
is a mutation and every patient has a
colorectal cancer
a different viewer application but the
relation is in the same team year after
and which is 594 G petition in finite
for G so then based on you know how your
cancer or type of mutation right now we
can prescribe different medications for
melanoma it would be when were on a
press tour we metonym for colorectal
cancer v600e mutation humor afternoon
and Somerset XML and for the five nine
four Chi invitation could be traumatic
name or Combe Magna so this gives you in
one example of gene and variant analysis
in the context of a patient's disease so
so moving on to should integrated data
analysis so so naturally National
Research Council the National Academies
recommended you know to create
individual centric information Commons
they gave an example that who will Maps
you their different layers GSI layers
have been organized you know organized
for geographical positioning can same
thing be done further for the genome you
exhaust genomes that we can all
microbiomes
all you know different layers can be put
together to generate a better picture of
the patient disease and this is
something that the current focus of my
research and we are trying to integrate
Mullenix kind of and the world data and
the goal is to create a knowledge
network where we can utilize to you know
meaningful drug diagnostics combinations
so that the right drugs can be given to
right patients and right time you know
morrible also is to X or in drug
discovery causes time is a big factor
here so this is just to give you one
example where we have together two
different there's micro RNA layer the
expression micron amounts and in
genomics so this is a melanoma patient
so so in this particular mountain
operation was driven by
raspy history kinase and MCM pathogens
this pathway was you know worried or
represented in these in those tumors and
we have a micro RNA and we found it a
true that micro RNA was you know
underrepresented in this tumors and when
we or expressed the micro RNA in found
that the tumor volume in mice when
dramatically down so that was very
encouraging and this is you get in what
you see represented by be the bell
raffinate alone which is drawing that
you treat melanomas and what we can also
reduce to Mali but what we're very
impressive when you see plus with me so
that's the combination where we combine
micro RNA expression with a number of
treatment and we saw very dramatic
reductions Pahlavi and since this all
opens prospects of my chronic special
and targeted recombination no very
encouraging there are you know there are
data integration as there are many
talents as you can see from the slide
right here data is you know in patient
data in the clinic is fragmented so we
have to find a way how we can integrate
then they data to create a you know
integrated BSS for personal health this
is one of the challenges that you know
you should be as a community be
interesting and another challenge is you
know data as you can see is is you know
silo in different institutional
firewalls and and so you know our field
of data is considered as sacred and you
know how to find you know how to form
those and you know consortiums of
network sharing sharing models which
will allow allow
they have to be chaired one of the
example is ga4gh global ask for genomics
and health that allows us to you know
share data and also one more problem is
how to foster more collaborative
research or creativity
academia biotech for pharma companies
but some sort of shared IP you know some
sort of consortium governing shared
ideas and these are some of the problems
that we should be working as a community
to solve so that everything make a great
advance in very different where you know
in a very fast and faster way as
community so the big data ecosystem is
to make you can see this is a slice
presence you can see there are a lot of
infrastructure companies there are
analytics companies there also you know
there are application you know their
applications company this is where this
is where the life science Parmen is
pooled in there also security company
there are a company that will be working
on you know there are also you know
open-source algorithm utilize to conduct
your research and there are data sources
and you can you can use that for your
research too so but moving forward
affordability and cost of precision
medicine will also drive individual
decisions so we have to also find a way
to really is to find how we can reduce
the cost of the integrated comics
analysis and also how to make the payers
convinced the payers to pay for these
analysis to lend the locations of going
forward and promises of precision
medicine so the next is expected
benefits of precision approaches at
different stages of clinical care
pathway and you know the precision
medicine can be utilized in article
to identify patients they respond most
appropriately little bit because
everything's thoroughly and also - and
you know also in recruitment and
enrollment averaging the study
population using predictive biomarkers
and also post approval the precision
medicine can be used optimize treatment
decisions to ensure that the right drug
can be used to create a shunt at the
right time so and so all three stages
prevention diagnostics precision
medicine can make approach can be
utilized to improve health related
outcomes so you know improve the health
or all you know healthcare the outcomes
of patients and you know precision
medicine babies the drugs have a high
likelihood of getting a true baffi
variability in listing which responders
from non responders or toxic responders
and this is a this is just to show you
that in 2007 alone over 30% of new drugs
have drug approvals the personalized
medicine some sort of biomarker
components so seating you know and this
is a link to FDA's drugs available with
you know genetics and label they're
approximately 240 drugs that are there
are in the list link or interested you
can take a look at it and and last but
not least at healthcare stakeholders and
their role in success of precision
medicine so there are there are many
stakeholders and they have all their
they're responsible these government's
policy makers research institutions you
know biomedical science community hamish
critical industry consumer groups
regulatory bodies so we all have to come
together and and and work together to
deliver the promise of precision
medicine and you know to do that we have
created an organization is nonprofit
organization American Association social
medicine is
the goal is to reduce adverse drug
events by accelerating the field of
decision medicine to research education
communication and collaboration to
foster a new medical basis and also
facilitates a dialogue between the four
pieces of precision medicine patients
providers public health planners ie
government and peers to work together to
achieve the goal of delivering improved
outcomes at a reduced cost and so you
know we foster dialogue we are in
organized meetings and networking events
to to get folks together in a room and
[Music]
innovation you know communication and
innovation believe that this will take
the field forward much faster way and if
you are in the precision medicine you
will be hearing from us and so creature
perspectives
you know precision medicine you know it
has received very good press and you
know being are we are we have got the
you know popular support and
representation I personally believe in
the model of you know promising lesson
you know you know delivering more but
this kind of press we have a lot of
responsibility on our on our on our
shoulders that we have to deliver so you
know also in advancement advancements
artificial intelligence you know
recently have presented a new promise to
take the precision medicine to the next
level so you know deep learning
algorithms diagnosed you know can
diagnose diabetic retinopathy skin
cancer lesions at par with the physician
that that means almost as well as
physicians and AI also interprets
radiology votes with now ninety-one
percent accuracy this all now the
complex tasks of data analytics can be
you know tool into you know can be done
by artificial intelligence that
health you know help with a lot of data
data analytics changing the challenges
that we're facing in medicine and also
you know last decade they can belong to
medical products the equipment's
hardware's consumables currently they
can be a living you know it belongs to
medical platforms so we have you know
wearables we have big data you know we
have generating a lot of data you know
and and also health analytics doing a
lot of health analytics but next decade
will be launching medical solutions so
and robotics AI augmented reality this
goal so what we can do with the data
that we're generating in with thank you
so that will be the challenge of the
next decade and also the few single
figure it presents artificial
intelligent market for healthcare
applications worldwide so in 2014 it was
six six six sixty six hundred and sixty
three point eight million dollars but in
2021
its projected to be six point six six
billion dollars so so the next thing it
belongs to finding medical solutions and
AI and robotics will define your health
and you know and you know you all may
know about the government's all of us
initiatives initially you know they're
trying to create a research cohort of
approximately 1 million American
volunteers to share in genetic data
biological samples and diet lifestyle
information all linked to their
electronic health record system this
will pioneer a new model for doing
science
you know emphasizing engaged
participation responsible data sharing
in privacy protection and on in all the
folks who are interested in big data
analytics and AI for them this will be a
goldmine for for innovation not so
trying to solve a lot of data analytics
problem and the government may face so
she's your future of precision medicine
the colloquy is right you know we we
have moved I think from past in the
center based you know medicine to
present which is a pattern base
medicine you know and two future will be
algorithm based medicine future I think
you know the drugs and algorithms will
be launched together that's what I
sometimes chew and manage you know the
disease and so this is a little
schematic schematics that I have put
where you know you can have patients
presented at the clinic could personal
integrated economics will be performed
and which plus imaging data which will
be analyzed to create a personal
molecular classifier you know which will
be you know it can be sent to physician
and this is digital health comes into
the play and you know and the physician
can see that and and and then deliver
the promise of precision medicine which
is right drugs to rise patients and
right time so you know I whenever I know
about precision medicine I always talk
about and and talk about the you know
safety in security so you know Gina
genetic information and
non-discrimination Act which is which
provides strong protection Americans
against discrimination based on their
genetic information when it comes to
health insurance and employment again
these protections apply to residents of
all 50 states and territories
however Gina is not a comprehensive
privacy law and it does not address all
possible forms with genetic
discrimination so we need you know
unique innovation around that
however Gina is the strong and essential
first step towards that position has so
with that being said I leave you with
this final painting it's called the
doctor my new feels and you know if
presence concern comes looking at the
child who is sick and doctor you know
contemplating by looking at the patient
and what I believe that
advancement advancements the precision
medicine will will provide doctors more
tools and more tools to make their
informed decisions to deliver the
promise of precision best thank you very
much
thank you dr. Mishra for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion at the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for all right let's get started what
areas can a I be utilized in advancing
precision medicine yeah yeah you know
behinds are very and I'm very much
excited you know to utilize AI in the
early stage of drug discovery you know
where a lot of innovation really happens
to utilize AI accelerate that the early
stages of drug discovery I can be also
utilized in in you know in running and
monitoring clinical trials and of course
AI can you know when it comes to the
health and the data that we are she a
bigger net via generating I think to
make sense of that data actually I can
help our you know our understanding and
make our life easier by analyzing all
that data for us so I think it can help
I think almost every aspects of expect
we will be using especially missed and
how can busy became to call on some
precision medicine that's the
interesting question so you know
beautiful health or now we call it the
little health right but well eventually
it will be all health so this it's so we
will we will you know have
you know patients coming to you know
they can make appointments online they
can you know you know they pay all the
you know to physicians online using
their phones and they even their
symptoms can be monitored using the fog
you know and you know so so the digital
health can will become a really
integrated part of the medicine in
future that's what I believe and the
precision medicine will you know in
medicine overall will utilize utilize
advancements in dental health and if you
see if you remember the definition of
position that is analyzed on lifestyle
lifestyle King is our lifestyle the
patient's lifestyle so so to monitor
that I think it'll help you know would
be very handy you know generate the data
that's presented to a physician and the
message you can do you think a I would
replace precision oh that's the that's a
you know yes you know some samples have
different conflicting views but what I
believe that I so I'm a very big
advocate of you know non artificial
intelligence but intelligence
augmentation you know so I think the AI
is a misnomer that you know intelligence
augmentations
it's a algorithm that we're designing
their augmenting intelligence of
physicians so what we will do is we so
with with this model I guess an example
the smartphones we have become which he
became more smarter you know we can you
know we can make smarter decisions using
some of the you know apps on our phones
right so similarly you know as with all
these algorithms you know the I will
empower physicians and you know some of
the mundane mundane tasks that I've done
by physicians you know that could be
taken care of by AI so that you know so
that physician friend
you know report can be submitted
invariably physicians can take a look
and make an informed decision so I I
mentioned that you know they do a
classifier so you not needed it so it I
think I will become integrated integral
part of the medical system but I don't
think it will replace physicians already
will replace certain tasks that we do
you know we do today so I think I like
the Stanford called Stanford Stanford
run an article where they said that AI
will heal so physicians also really is
who will not adopt to AI will be
replaced by a radiologist doctor
so you know similarly physicians who
will adapt to AI will will replace
physicians who would not so I think
that's been absolutely the feature we
will see more physicians you know
learning teaching themselves all the
modern technology to help patients make
do to help patients and promise and
bring the promises of this machine
medicine to the client I mean we have
how do we bring together all the
stakeholders in the precision medicine
yeah that's the best one of the you know
big challenges that we are facing right
now so we are we are trying to so that's
why we started the association position
medicine and I think with that we you
know we aim to organize conferences we
organize training programs for
physicians and we are you know planning
to planning to also bring all the
stakeholders together to just austere
communication and foster dialogue and
and try to present problems what are the
problems in the field and how can we
solved and I I'm a big fan of
communications in education okay the
communications Amanda captured we then
put people in their own you know
solutions come come out so the
communications will bring solution so I
think we have to
we have to actively as a community
investing in them in trying to bring the
minds together and sought out sought out
solutions to these these problems that
are caused by lack of communication so
yeah I think yeah I think yeah if there
we build more platforms like that you
know this will be very beneficial as the
community lost
further excellent well like to once
again thank dr. Mishra for his
presentation I would also like to thank
labyrinth for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from libraries letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay but you share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye